i work for a bank i don't want to do
that for the rest of my life you know
my goal in life is to just have a bit
more freedom
[Music]
hey what's up guys welcome back to
winners on a wednesday and in this video
i'm going to be picking the brains of a
man who's become a property millionaire
he had a little house which he
refinanced and then bought a whole bunch
of houses and he's done super super well
in the world liverpool area and i
thought it'd be really helpful and
inspiring for you to learn exactly how
he did it property by property step by
step how he financed it using the equity
of his home how he's done the refurb and
kept it really cheap so that you can do
the same thing too but the first step to
being successful in property of course
is to go ahead and smash the like button
and also subscribe to the channel so you
don't miss a future video again firstly
thank you for coming out to my house hi
samuel nice to meet you it's a real
pleasure so you've done over the last 18
months you've gone from a normal guy
in debt with one house to now being a
serial property investor and uh
technically financially free and also
once your fifth house completes a
property millionaire so it'll be just
over a million
dollars
so i wanted to kind of really pick your
brain because a lot of people ask me
they say
how do you refinance the house how do
you how do you have to get bridging
um how can you get multiple mortgages
and also you have to do lots of refurbs
so i really just wanted to understand
the concept of how you've done it and
also what was it that inspired you in
the first place where did this all come
from yeah absolutely so about 18 months
ago
during the pandemic
i was working from home it was just me
in the house at the time
you know i had about 500 pounds in my
bank account
it's raining outside i'm miserable i'm
not seeing anybody
so i just started looking on youtube
you know as you know you binge watch
things and
came across uh
came across yourself uh samuel lee's i
think this guy you know isn't talking
about property uh a guy called grant
cardone i know he's a good friend of
yours
so i'd never heard of you before or
grant cardone
and i didn't know too much about
property either i just thought it was
something that
really rich folk did and you know he
needed loads of capital to get started
um
but i just had something
in me that you know wanted more
so i started
consuming the information uh that that
you were giving about refinancing
property
so with me since i was a kid i've always
had these sort of um
i suppose you can say negative forces
people in my life saying you know you
can't remortgage a property why do you
want to remortgage and get yourself in
more debt
you know um i i love my dad he's been
really supportive but he he was one of
the the ones that were saying you know
find a good bank
get a mortgage and that's it stick with
them
it's like yeah but but that's uh this
this guy samuel leeds is telling me to
refinance remortgage boost the value
take the money out no no that's that's
um you know you don't need to put
yourself at risk with things like that
and i thought you know what i'm just
going to take a step into it i'm going
to take a risk because really at that
point in life i didn't have much to lose
anyway it felt like i was just
you know in my day job which i really
like
but i wasn't
wealthy um also during the pandemic uh i
read a book called rich that poor dad
which i know uh influenced you a lot
yeah classic absolutely and i've never
read it before and it was like
almost like i'm an alien and all these
new things are like uh coming to me
but the the words of wisdom how the
wealthy have assets and how the middle
class have debt and the difference
between good and bad debt yeah i was
like that's it that's what i need to
start these principles i need to start
implementing
so
i was calling around a number of
different brokers
didn't have much luck at first um
you know that
i just wasn't clicking with the right
broker um i ended up becoming friends
with a really good one on the whirl
call mark
and we've become really good friends and
he
he suggested you know we can release x
amount from the property that you're
living in yeah i didn't realize this was
even possible i just thought okay i've
got a mortgage
i didn't even think to release more
equity and you can release up to 75
of the worth of the property
so
that's what i did so i took out 25 000
from my first property
took ages to go through
um and then when i got it it was like
this golden yeah i've never had 25 grand
in my bank before and that that feeling
of like i felt like so like
rich you know yeah like it doesn't seem
like much but to me at the time it was
like wow this is some this is good money
so
i was looking around and
i found the property on the world for 80
000
but the market at the time was just
so crazy it was every every house that i
was looking at was gone by the time i
put an offer in you know there was like
10 viewings each each time i'd go
so i got lucky and i bought this house
a really good price put put 20k in so
put 25 in and i'm in my day job i'm a
project manager so i work with budgets i
work with planning
so i noticed that these skills were
something that i could bring to the
property world
so
i uh you know i used my property
management skills and
i managed to re
kind of renovate this property
for for less than five thousand pounds
so i've got a really nice kitchen for
around two grand
oh wow it was yeah it was like this
rapid kitchen's place right in liverpool
really good um
i think it's just like one bloke that
works as a sort of a broker almost and
he's packaged it up as an opening but
yeah two grand really good um nice and
clean got a bathroom for a thousand
pound
got the electric set up did a lot of the
painting and thing myself electrician
but for less than five grand i was able
to boost the value of this property for
132 000 pounds
holy
moly that is the perfect buy refurbished
refinance property right there that's
struck gold so you bought it for how
much 80. you bought it for 80s and then
the new value was 1-3-2
and of course following
the teachings and principles absolutely
what do you do with that yeah so your
book um
i always get this wrong
buy low rent high
so read your book uh watch binge watch
hours of your videos of how to renovate
property how to get a good deal um how
to search the market i was such a
newcomer to it
i appreciate that this deal isn't common
um so i got a really good deal in a low
market yeah and took almost 40 000 out
of it
yeah and then
in a matter of months you know i've gone
from sort of 500 pounds miserable on my
own in lockdown
uh to happen really like 40 50 grand in
my bank account
so i just carried on you know um
and one of the things that i'd recommend
something that i've done and you've
mentioned this as well is having a power
team yeah
having people that you can really trust
um so i've got a really good broker i've
got a really good real estate agent my
solicitors are brilliant
so i've got a team that i can
really just call at any time
um and we tend to help each other um we
make things happen
i managed to get two more
and repeat the process um so both of
those were in liverpool and how did you
finance those did you finance them from
the refinance of the second property you
then pulled the money out and then
recycled it into another property
yeah and
it's so bizarre but it i almost become
became desensitized to the money it
didn't feel like i was
wasting 50 grand it felt like i was
investing and using the principles that
that you've
you've communicated on your videos i'm a
big fan of grant cardone as well and
i think you're very similar to gram
cardone
and i think what separates separates you
from him is
you're more practical to the uk property
market
while i think grant's more i think he's
like a tony robbins type he's very
energetic isn't he
so both of you i think without you
realizing it were my mentors yeah
um
and
i just thought you know just keep going
and i think one of the things grant says
is cash is trash yeah i don't always
agree with that i think some cash is is
good but that's his one of his things
so i bought two more
repeated the process um
and again during the process i just did
a lot of it myself so
you know i'm somebody two years ago i
couldn't even paint a wall i didn't know
how to sand anything i'm just a terrible
diy person
but you know it's just slowly i've
learned how to do some of this stuff
and you want to just keep the cost low
you know so when you're renovating any
any contractor that you're talking to
you have to hustle with them and haggle
and barter and you just don't take the
first price so i'm a salesman at heart
so for 10 years in my early life i was i
was in sales
and you teach
really great principles you have a
system in place of what people can do
from zero to
to being financially free
but what i would also say is that
there's a little bit of skill involved
as well
and um i was thinking of it it's a bit
like sort of climbing a mountain or
climbing everest
a teacher and a mentor like yourself can
teach
give somebody the right tools
you can give all the equipment you can
show them how to climb even
you know like the sherpas they drag
somebody up the mountain to force them
up there
but there is going to be times when
that person has to sort of jump over a
wall or something themselves
there are going to be parts in the
journey that's where your natural skill
comes in
so i remember when i bought one of the
houses there was already two offers in
place
and they were higher than what i wanted
to offer
so i think um i think she'd had an offer
of 112 and i wanted to offer one six one
one zero six
so i thought okay let me try and work
some magic let me see if i can sell my
own deal to her
so it was on um purplebricks so you can
message them on that so a messenger and
just said look my young investor you
know live about 10 minutes from you
really love the house you know would you
like to meet up for a chat
and you know
you know just discuss a deal
so we we ended up becoming really good
friends
bizarrely and during the wholesale
process she was telling me about her job
and things and texting so really bizarre
rapport
but she actually accepted my offer which
was six thousand pounds less than what
she'd already been offered
but i think to myself
i've sold something there so she's
actually left 6k on the table
to to do to work with me
so so i think there's something to that
i think you need to have that you need
to have good people skills yeah work on
building a rapport and you know this you
know you're in that you're in the
business i'm still sort of learning it
um but i thought that was really
profound yeah
it's almost like you've got the
the skills of being able to do a
property deal the finance side the hard
skills and then there's the soft skills
of being able to actually
deal with people and i feel like that's
the case not just in getting the deal
but also in getting the refurb done
also in getting the tenants filled and
managing the tenants
in getting the mortgage broker and the
solicitors to hurry up
it's a people business absolutely and
when you can when you can combine the
skills of property with and ultimately
money doesn't come from property it
comes from people
and when you can deal with people in
order to talk to people i think you're
right i think i'd say
massively and and you've learned from
from me about the property side of
things but then obviously people like
grant goddard sales peoples and grand
teachers both and i teach both but um
talk to me about
a year and a half ago you've got this
clearly you've got this fire in your
belly you've been binge watching youtube
videos you've been reading my books and
doing some of my online
video researching
but you've got your family
and your friends telling you be careful
don't do it
don't get into debt just pay off your
mortgage keep your head down in your job
how did you manage to
go ahead and do it on your own
i mean talk me through that because i
can i imagine a lot of people can relate
to that um you know they've got people
telling them to be careful and holding
them back yeah absolutely almost
everybody who i mentioned this idea to
said don't do it it's almost it was like
100 problems of why not to do it
yeah and just something really sort of
profound
i don't want to go sort of too deep but
when i was a kid i remember with my dad
we were watching a boxing fight
on tv chris eubank or someone
i thought and then i was like dad i'd
love to go to vegas one day to a boxing
fight
and then he said
no people like us don't go to events
like that
almost you know 30 odd years ago
i thought to myself what does he mean by
people like us can't go to events like
that
and then i've heard sort of things
certain people from certain places they
say you know
you know if you go to dubai or if you go
to miami it's fake you know it's fake
people like us don't go to places like
that that's a different world
and that's always stuck with me because
it's like well
why is it fake you know why can't you
enjoy the nicer things you know
it's almost that some people are living
in this sort of matrix and it's like
anything outlandish and really cool
is is just not attainable
and it isn't for you you know
and i think
what i was getting from certain people
was you know almost like you know be
quiet stand there sit in the corner and
just do your job
and and that's it you know do what
everyone else does
and
you know for me it was like well
actually i don't want to do what
everyone else is doing i don't want to
be like in a job all my life
you know not not thriving you know
so breaking away from that
really using the matrix analogy it
really was kind of like stepping out of
the matrix it was such a very difficult
and all the while while i'm battling
with these emotions and these thoughts
and you know no no don't do it don't do
it
you know i was watching videos of your
teachings of take action take action
just do it
and in my day job you know project
manager
we know that there's risk
but good planning mitigates the risk so
of course they can crash the property of
course when you buy a house there could
be a huge dam problem
that takes thousands to fix there's
going to be problems there always is
but you have to try and plan ahead for
that you know to mitigate those problems
and you know that with all the big
projects that you work on nothing ever
goes smoothly it's just how you plan
plan the project
so taking action i think
for me i've always had something
inside that once more you know i'm happy
with what i've got
you know i'm not into extravagant things
but
i want more i want to go on the nice
holidays i want to go to the i want to
enjoy life you know you can't can't all
be depressing in work
so i think what i would say is just
taking action is really important and
and for me that was really difficult it
took a it took a long time and a lot of
kind of
you know tunnel vision
to to take that first step of
refinancing my existing place
yeah yeah
now it doesn't feel like a big step now
it's like
you know i'd do it 10 times over but at
the time it was like
is this safe is this right you know
everyone else is saying don't do it no
so i think
you know i i can't be the only one that
that feels that way and i think taking
action
and just planning for any problems is
is the key
yeah really important
give give me some practical tips on the
refurb so you managed to get this whole
refurb done for five grand i think
that's where a lot of people mess up i
mean when you're doing a buy refurbished
refinance ultimately there's three
figures that you need to get wrong you
need to make sure you buy the right
price you need to make sure that the
refurb comes over the right price and
you need to make sure that the value is
high enough for you to then refinance
pull your money out on a 75 loan to
value so you got that refurb really
cheap i know you had some of the work
yourself
just give us some tips on how to get
that refurb so cheap yeah so what what
things i started off with so you've got
a really nice place here so uh the walls
for me are really important and the
lighting um
so what i did in all three of them was
was take the wallpaper off
which is easy anyone can do that really
just scraper or wallpaper remover
so clear the walls
sand it all down
again anyone can do that
what i did so i can't plaster so i you
know i'm not that good but i use poly
filler um i'm there so with my hand
doing poly filler so you sort of cover
all the gaps sand it all down
and just give it two or three coats of
white paint
similar to what you've got here and it
just gives it a really fresh look yeah
and it's not that hard to do you know
you can do it
you know skirting boards
um i brought an electrician in uh for a
couple of days like 100 pounds a day so
200 quid for a guy to just fix some
light fixtures in i've got something you
can buy like uh cheap light fixtures
from argos for you know 15 20 quid that
look nice
but you know not not that expensive
so once you've got the walls and the
lighting i think for me that was like a
big part of it
and and then the expensive parts uh
uh kitchen bathroom and carpets yeah um
they're the um the big sort of the heavy
price items
so carpets you know about a thousand
pounds to do the hallway rooms
uh kitchen i found a really good place
in near in liverpool
so for around two thousand two and a
half thousand pounds they do these
kitchen fits in two days
and i've literally pinched the
contractor as well so it's a guy that
does the work for them now he does a
homework for me
a guy called john so we've become really
good friends
um but they come in it's a family
business these contractors they just fit
it two days you've got
it's not like the best quality but it
looks really nice yeah and then that's
sometimes all that matters and it's a
cheap tempted house at the end of the
day we're not talking about
trying to do your own millionaire
mansion um we're talking about you know
100 houses here so to spend 15 grand on
the kitchen would be disproportionate
with the cost of the house um okay well
that's really helpful i've noticed a lot
you've talked about
who you know as well like the friends
contacts mortgage broker agents and i
really believe that it's not just about
what you know it's also who you know
yeah give me some tips on pulling these
people in like even a mortgage broker i
see people they watch a video of mine
and i'll say i'll talk about how you can
refinance your house and they'll go to
their bank to get a refinance and then
oh my bank told me no and it's like
because you needed to speak to a
mortgage advisor and
how did you get how did you manage to
get these in with these people
so it was difficult so the broker uh
garco mark
is just like a godsend you know i owe
him so much um
he works for a company um but he's the
guy that i work with um
it
i was talking to a number of different
brokers in the early stages and they
were just very um
some of them were unprofessional some of
the bigger banks wasn't weren't getting
back to me for weeks
and it's like well it's almost as if
they don't want my business
um some some of us were making me sign
up to this thing putting all my sort of
income and outcome expenditures in
but just wasn't leading to anything they
were just coming up with inflated prices
so i i sort of stumbled upon a company
in in the world
uh concept mortgages i don't mind saying
it really i'd highly recommend them um
and it's so bizarre samuel but
everything i've asked of them they've
delivered so i've said okay i want to re
remortgage this place i want to try and
get 30 000 out and i want my repayment
amount to be as low as possible
and i'd give a figure
and so far
they've made it happen nice yeah so i
think
you know what you know who you know and
also your mindset determination i'm sure
it's not all been easy was there a
moment when you wanted to quit
absolutely so it's such a weird feeling
so i know
we've mentioned sort of property
millionaire um i don't feel like a
property millionaire at this stage um
although when you look at the numbers
that's that's what it is but
really over the last 18 months there's
been a lot of hard work
and a lot of expenditures as well
so it's almost going back to the
mountain analogy it is sort of climbing
a mountain you just there are going to
be ups and downs
and you have to persevere it's not an
easy journey yeah
and i think anyone who thinks it's going
to be easy and that's just going to be
like this
you know
i don't know if you don't mind me
mentioning but some videos calling you
out saying i've tried this course and
then
you know it didn't quite work
and i think to myself well actually
there's been hundreds of winners on a
wednesday
of people who
have done the courses and have succeeded
so what i would say to
that person doing a video trying to call
you out is well have you have you
overcome the challenges that
the mission has given you
because there are going to be it's not
going to be easy
have you been able to mitigate risks
have you been able to
you know have you given up
because people can give up they might
say okay screw this i'm not carrying on
with this
so there are pitfalls that you just have
to
you know fortune favors the brave and
yeah you have to be you have to
persevere
and and i think
you know
maybe that's what separates the
the people on dragon's den and the
millionaires to
to so they're not millionaires you know
they've persevered they've gone through
the challenges they've had that
you know overcome the fear almost yeah
and i think as well it's really
important that
you've got a strong reason why so when
the going gets tough rather than
thinking i'll forget this i'm going to
try and find an easier route or you
think no actually i've got a strong
reason why and i've got a fire that's
burning and even in the tough days
because yeah we can talk about how many
millions we've made or how many deals or
pulled all the money out and you know
you explain it in 30 seconds but
actually it might have been six months
worth of blood twenty years yeah so
for yourself um you know what's what
would you say
what's that strong reason why
so
so i i i've been working for for the man
for the last 11 years so i work for a
bank and and i really enjoy it i i love
working there really great people that i
work with and i enjoy and i'm not in a
position where i want to leave my day
job
but yeah i don't want to do that for the
rest of my life you know and
you see
see all these my goal in life is to just
have a bit more freedom to work on my
own projects
you know obviously that there are
financial
goals that set myself
but also i just want to work on
really big projects and something that
that you've said grant cardone and
others have said is that
you need high goals
if you wake up in the morning getting
your goals done and this is going to
sound a bit cheesy but if your goals
don't scare you a little bit
then they're not high enough
you know and i really believe in that
you know we have a sort of a depression
pandemic in in the world where a lot of
people are kind of slumped and miserable
it's because they don't have any goals
they're not working to anything they're
just in a in a job that they sort of
trudge along to
so i think for me i'm very goal-driven
you know just
in terms of the the why
freedom yeah finance
financial reasons as well
and just working with people you know
for for me i'm happiest when i'm
collaborating with people working on big
deals
and the for really the last 18 months
have been really fun as well
you know i'm 36 now but i've had more
fun in the last two years than ever
really yeah
you know i've been able to go on a as i
said before a nice holiday in dubai with
my girlfriend we you know we had a villa
and everything it was really nice you
know i could never have done that before
yeah so it does open doors and
you know i don't think money gives you
happiness where it does open doors and
gives you that freedom
so yeah have you surprised yourself over
the last 18 months did you know it was
gonna
would you have thought 18 months ago
when you first made the decision to
refinance your house that one house did
you know how far you'd come in 18 months
no no so the
feeling of that first deal
and i got you know i probably got a
little bit lucky because i bought the
house cheap and and
the value was so high afterwards
but it's so addictive you know like i
just want more and more now it's sort of
like a
like a like a drug almost you know that
feeling of success
and i just wanted the deals to get
bigger and bigger and i'm working on
something now which is a relatively big
deal now with sort of house
just buying a house of just over 200 000
and and then after that there'll be more
so yeah
one of the things i wanted to mention to
you as well so
it's been 18 months but i feel like i'm
right at the beginning really so
i went to your rent to rent uh course in
liverpool
so i haven't started rent to rent yet
but that's something i want to get into
hmos i haven't gotten to yet so i'm
going to go on your training course uh
to help me with hmos because i'm a
little bit nervous about it yeah i don't
know exactly what
in my head it feels like there's loads
of expense at the beginning
and then a little bit of skill involved
to fill the rooms
manage the properties so i just need
help with that but
i'm just i feel like i'm right at the
beginning yeah yeah and joint ventures
as well well i can't wait for part two
in another year when you've gone from
millionaire to multi-millionaire
millionaire property portfolio but um
you know massive congratulations to what
you've done there's been a lot of
information there so i'm sure my
subscribers will really enjoy it what
would you say your final words of wisdom
are for anyone watching today
i think final words of wisdom is
if you've got a goal
just go for it you know don't don't
listen to negative
you know
go for it take action
stay positive yeah and and and also just
work on knowledge as well so invest in
yourself
invest
in being around good people
and and yeah just go for it be ambitious
amazing well thanks so much adam for
coming out to my house today thank you
really appreciate it
guys i hope you found that useful what
an absolutely amazing guy
so many knowledge bombs and golden
nuggets dropped during those last that
last half an hour or so i tell you what
why don't you go ahead and hit the like
button also if you enjoyed the video let
me know what you like best about this
interview and i'll try and do more of it
so let me know in the comments if you
want to come down to the property
investors crash course which is
completely free where you can learn how
to also get started in property like
aiden did i'm going to the link in the
description
we've currently got free tickets
available limited spaces so get booked
now what are you waiting for do it now
and i'll look forward to seeing you guys
next time peace
[Music]